[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
Knorr I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank but I appreciate the count
stopping by from Sesame Street it's a
comedy podcast about death where two
brothers Hank and John Green will give
you some dubious advice answer your
questions and bring you all the week's
news from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon hi
John how are you uh you know the truth
like if I good we're gonna be perfectly
honest oh god no I don't want to know
the truth lie to me lie lie I can't I
can't lie I can't lie then that you
should ask me how I'm doing I Hank I
have had one of the most like
emotionally in terms of my professional
life just like emotionally up and down
weeks I can remember I've laughed I've
cried I've had panic attacks threw up
from nervousness it's just been up and
down it's been every which way but
Sunday as my mother used to say well
I've got that by the way that that old
phrase never made any sense to me I I
don't really know what it means because
Sunday isn't even away but it reminds me
of something else the answer to your
question is that I'm doing really well
right now like super well but I had some
had some hard times in my past but the I
just want to quickly tell you a story
which is that I used to always explain
to my now seven-year-old son when one
somebody would say something that was
just like a weird euphemism or something
that like doesn't make sense if you are
a literal translator of English as most
like four and five year olds are I would
just be like Henry that's an old saying
you know it's just an old saying and
here's what it means and one time I was
driving Henry back from picking up some
kind of horrible you know fast food
dinner that I'm sure his mother would
have not approved of and we're driving
back and he's eating his french fries in
the car seat and he says to me lemon
salty whales and I said what and he said
lemon salty whales and I said what and
he said dad it's just an old saying hey
John the world's been around for a long
time maybe it is maybe it is maybe
somewhere there's a culture that where
people are just like Oh lemon salty
whales got us again what what you gonna
do ha ha you know if you think you think
you're in control your life and you
think things are going pretty well and
then took lemon salty whales well
speaking of lemon salty whales John I
got this I got this microscope you know
recently yeah I do not have been having
a lot of fun with it you know sometimes
you'll turn your keyboard over and you
just tap it on your desk and just to
clean it out because there's some stuff
in there well I took that stuff and I
put it in a little pile and I put it on
the microscope plate and then I pointed
my microscope at it and don't do that
really mmm I didn't want to know what
your dead skin cells right it's just
it's so it's so many different things
how can so many different things get in
there it's just mmm
I would imagine it's just dead skin
cells which is one of the very few
things that I'm not pathologically
afraid of it's all see it was a bunch of
food it was a lot of food a lot of
little oh yeah whose party we like but
also things I didn't recognize and
you're like like the things that looks
like crystals and I don't know and maybe
I don't know if it's like the the
leavings of bugs as well maybe oh yeah i
bug poop mm-hmm yeah I do bugs poop of
course they've pooped John hmm they got
a red end and a back end and it goes
through the tube just like us I guess I
wasn't thinking about like like roaches
when I was thinking about bugs I was
thinking about you know like I don't
know like an amoeba oh well amoebas are
not bugs okay and I don't good they have
a waist but they don't no they do not
poop they don't have a tube amoebas all
right well with that noted let's move on
to some questions from our list
okay I got one that I thought I think we
had a good answer to John I think I
think that we've had a good answer to it
humanity has had a good answer to it or
at least the english-speaking human
humanity has and we need to share it
it's from Jade who asks dear Hank and
John I work in a therapy office and
about half of our clientele as couples
and families I usually refer to the
couple or family as the unit as you guys
as in your appointment started 10
minutes ago are you guys still able to
make it mm-hmm I've always disliked that
male nouns and pronouns are considered
universal / the default I'm sure that
our female clients are used to being
referred to as you guys and it probably
doesn't bother them too much but I as a
female know that they're know that if
there was a more inclusive word or
phrase people could use I would want
them to use it is there another word or
phrase that I can use to be more
inclusive I think there is of course
there is there is you want to say it on
three Hank yeah sure 1 2 3
y'all y'all have already invented this
word and just because it is closely
associated with the American South does
not mean that it is not a useful and
good word admittedly I am from the
American South I say y'all very
comfortably it doesn't sound weird to me
it never has but y'all is a great
gender-neutral word for the plural you
and solves one of the great problems in
English which is that you and you is
both singular and plural it's extremely
confusing and it needed to be addressed
and we have addressed it successfully so
this is a unrelated side note here when
I took Spanish in high school and
there's a plural noun for we know
sorrows and and it and because nouns in
Spanish are gendered there's no so
throes and there's no so thrust and if
you're a group of guys you're nosotros
and if you're group of girls you know so
thrust but my Spanish teacher literally
said this to me if it is a stadium of
women and there is one man it is
nosotros so like if it's a group of
split like multiple people but like all
you need is one dude - and I thought
that was like so
wrong and weird and bad but at the same
time like we say you guys for any group
of people that's true though it's it's
everywhere and and it is a convenience
and it is also illustrative I think
y'all is plenty Ella straight if
actually and I'm not backing down off of
my support for y'all it is the greatest
word that is not widely utilized in the
English language but I say illustrative
I mean it is a it is a Leicester ative
of a of a deeper thing and closer oh
yeah no it definitely is illustrative of
that of a system yes um yes quite quite
but I think I have another question and
it's very important I'm sorry I think we
need to get to it it's it's it's
time-sensitive okay okay and it's a hard
that's bad that's bad news because these
do take a while to get up Dear John and
Hank I have the same name as Trump's new
FBI director I'm afraid the Russians
will come after me what do I do
my claim to fame is my name Christopher
Rea Chris is easy solution here which is
just like wait a couple weeks because
he's not gonna be the next director of
the FBI Chris I mean even if he is he's
just gonna get fire yeah I mean that
mostl beat it's not a job with a long
this best-case scenario is director of
the FBI for 14 hours that's as good as
it's gonna get for Christopher Rai so if
you just hold on to your name you're
gonna be fine but that's not actually
what I would recommend because I also
disagree with the premise of the
question because I would argue that the
the Russians are not going to be coming
for Christopher Wren I don't know I I
don't know I don't know what the
Russians want John and that's what they
want Hank we have decided not to talk
about this in public in detail and I
think that is the right decision but you
and I have both received some
information that actual hackers
sponsored by an actual government have
pursued information related to us yes
that's correct
it is deeply disturbs I'm trying to
choose my words extremely carefully it
is deeply disturbing to us and also a
really highlights how common this must
be since Hank and I are not I would say
a level targets yeah like if I were a
foreign government and I wanted to
access even the the information related
to say a thousand Americans I just don't
think I would put me on the list
definitely not on the list I mean what
they probably do join us they just go
through Twitter and and they try and hit
anybody who has a substantial number of
followers and and they're just you know
just information gathering but yeah it
is really like it's super weird it's
super weird to get get that note it's
scary I mean there's no getting around
it so Christopher Rea to be totally
honest with you I would probably turn on
two-factor authentication on your on
your email and all your social media
accounts that matter to you that's my
honest advice I I would do that if I
were you I don't think that's an
overreaction no yeah and it's it's you
know it's not just that the Russians
coming for you anybody wants access just
gonna stop you right there
now do not know if it was the Russian
government now and and even if it were I
would just like to State for the record
that I think the Russian government has
often been misunderstood and very nice
folks just like they're doing a really
good job leading the country of Russia
and if anything I think that they need
to have more influence on American
politics so I just want to state that
that is my I am pink I am a coward the
other things I learned from this
experience I am a weak weak man oh well
yeah I mean it's it's weird when
somebody comes for you and it's like I
learned something about myself today I
just want to have a good time
be dealing with that I just want to have
a good safe life Jesus Christ just let
me stay here in Indianapolis and have a
normal life oh my god that was my
immediate reaction so yeah I mean
usually I would be like oh this is not a
big deal just go by your middle name or
we would come up with a bunch of jokes
but I actually did want to tell you to
go ahead and turn on cam factor
authentication it's the least that you
can do mm-hmm
and though it's probably the most that
you can do this question comes from
Wesley who asks dear Hank and John what
is the best way to introduce my young
son to Star Wars Petra should I try and
hold back as much as I can until he's
between four and five and then show him
the original trilogy or should I throw
caution to the wind and allow my own
Star Wars obsession to spill over into
his life as well laser swords and burp
rags Wesley so I have a pretty strong
opinion about this Hank well I mean
because I've been through Oh Oh John
this morning we put Oren for the first
time into the Star Wars but cute thing
that you got him by the way yeah he is
now big enough to wear it it's adorable
so he's already starting like he's seven
months old and he's already a fan right
but but he hasn't seen the movies yet
here's my theory
and I'm gonna try to say this without
spoilers there's something that happens
in those movies specifically toward the
end of Empire Strikes Back
that is a oh wow holy crap oh my gosh
moment it's one of the great ohmygosh
moments in the history of any movie and
your kid has to be old enough in that
moment to have that oh wow
experience or else the the trilogy will
kind of be lost on them now I guess they
can watch the prequels whenever but yeah
but movies 4 5 & 6
I think you have to get that oh wow
moment now I have friends who showed who
are big believers that the order should
will you share it with your kids should
be first movie for Star Wars a new home
and then the prequels and then movie 5
so you can get the full
of that oh my gosh moment but I think
your kids have to be old enough to get
that and also kind of maybe old enough
to be able to watch the not
insignificant amount of violence but and
then there's the secondary issue which
is that if you wait too long the whole
thing gets spoiled on the freakin
playground oh yeah yeah yeah well that's
the thing I I don't really know how to
be a human in the world who hasn't been
spoiled on that spoiler I mean you
totally can be I there's lots of humans
in the world who haven't been spoiled on
that spoiler but it is the the extent as
far as I can tell the only thing that
happens on the playground and Henry
school is that the kids swap spoilers
for all the books that they're reading
like we're reading Harry Potter right
now and Wow and I mean it's not just
that Henry knows some spoilers Henry
knows like an incredible errs he knows
he's essentially read but been read the
books by his classmates in such a way
that like while we're reading the book
he'll be like you know what's about to
happen and I'll be like no I don't know
what's about to happen even though I do
and he'll be like dragons
and I'll be like dragons and I'll say
and not just any dragon a hungarian
horntail
well that's that's that's kind of it
really like I like the idea of people
like telling these stories to each other
in their own way there's something
that's something knight-like especially
children like I think they love the
story so much they want to tell each
other the story and like it becomes you
know it's a and they get to practice
their storytelling skills and and they
get to entertain each other in that way
like I kind of like that and that you
know that might be more important than
you know getting that big oh my gosh
moment but maybe not but but but but
Wesley there's really good news for your
specific situation which is that if you
want to save that the the you know the
original trilogy you can because there
is a lot of Star Wars stuff that doesn't
have anything to do with the original
trilogy
that's very good point he was rather
wars
yeah you can there is so much kid
focused Star Wars stuff for you to show
your children yeah that's a great point
Inc I mean yeah and you can save that
you can save the original trilogy for
when they are old enough for that on
that front I have to say there's a
series of Star Wars kind of like middle
grade and whyyy novels that have come
out lately one was written by Beth Revis
one by Adam kid which they're really
good so that might be something that you
can share with them as well okay this
question comes from our old friend
anonymous who writes Dear John and Hank
I'm a 17 year old gay girl living in a
Middle Eastern country and I am
extremely privileged I go to one of the
best high schools in my city and I live
in a highly comfortable life surrounded
by people who love and support me my
dilemma is I still hate it here I'm
miserable living in this country even
though I have so much privilege I feel
stifled and depressed that I can't be
Who I am I am so tired of having to be
in the closet to everyone because I
could actually go to jail for it and I
don't want to hate it I feel like I have
no right to hate where I live when I
have such a comfortable life and other
people are suffering so much more than I
am even in the same city going to bad
schools barely enough to eat and
horrible health care is it okay that I'm
not happy and dislike my country even
after my life has been amazing here hope
and feathers anonymous no yeah it's fine
that's fine I mean first of all you you
can you can like some things about your
life and about about how your life is
and about the privileges you've had and
also dislike other things yeah about
your life and about and about how you
are being controlled and not allowed to
be the way that you are yeah I mean
that's an extreme form of oppression to
not be able to be yourself and to have
forces that are larger than you saying
that who you are is not okay and that
who you are is in fact illegal which is
what what the government is telling you
and that's a very very hard thing to
hear it's a dehumanizing thing to hear
and I don't think that there's that the
privileges that you've enjoyed in any
way
lessen or diminish that would it would
it be harder to be the same person and
having not enjoy those privileges of
course it would be but that doesn't mean
that that your pain and your experience
isn't real and isn't painful because it
certainly is I mean that that sounds
really really difficult to me I want to
be really careful here not to out people
but I know people who are living in
similar situations and it is extremely
difficult even if you have all of the
privileges in the world all the
structural privileges in the world all
the money in the world is it is
extremely difficult to be told by your
community and your government that who
you are as a person is illegal and wrong
and not fully human I mean that's it
those are incredibly difficult things to
hear yeah and I mean there's there are
also hopefully maybe ways to to like
things about your your culture and about
your traditions while also really
disliking that part of your of your
country of the thing that you are
inevitably a part of like it is you know
where you are will always be a part of
you and and you can you can hate that
thing and but but hopefully still not
hate everything about this other piece
of your identity which is you know your
home yeah but that's it's a very
difficult thing and I also don't want to
yeah I don't want to pretend that Hank
or I can give you a clear answer on that
I can tell you that as I hope you know
you're not alone in that and that the
struggle for justice and the struggle
for accepting people as fully human it's
gonna take a while it's gonna be
difficult but I think we see in human
history causes for hope so I hope I hope
that that gets better for you I hope
that you're more comfortable with your
life as time goes on but I also want you
to know that
you shouldn't certainly be beating
yourself up over feeling that pain
because it seems to me that that pain is
very real this next question comes from
Cory who asks dear Hank and John so as a
14 soon to be 15 year old my hormones
and my genetics make it so that a good
amount of acne tends to appear on my
face at the same time hair tends to
sprout from my face as well not wanting
to go through the commitment of growing
a full beard also let me be frank you
probably can't I have to on multiple
occasions shave my face but with said
acne it can be very difficult to do that
without cutting my face so I ask whether
it would be better just to wait till I'm
done with the whole puberty thing or is
there some magical trick to not cutting
your face well you've come to the right
place Cory because Hank and I are both
experts in really bad pubescent facial
hair and also you know a fair amount of
though certainly not not that the worst
acne that has ever happened which is
like can be a really difficult and
painful thing what I will say don't use
a razor you get an electric shaver thing
ER and and that will make it so much
easier and so much less painful and also
you'll have fewer scabs and fewer
bleeding and less bleeding and all that
so the get get an electric shaver with a
guard you know they can though over the
life of it it would probably be about
the same price as buying razors anyway
and if you can't afford that then ask
ask your parents to help you with this
thing that is difficult and hopefully
they they will and can uh yeah I totally
disagree with your advice what I do I
don't I mean your rock so Hank unlike
you I went to boarding school from high
school and also I hit puberty very late
which meant that I experienced like most
of my puberty related learning from my
peers there are parts of that that I can
recommend there are many parts that I
can say are not but not the best not the
best and one of the ones that isn't the
best is that my
tenth grade girlfriend Fran taught me
how to shave because she become fed up
with what she referred to as my
fisher-price my first mustache a a joke
that like several other jokes Fran used
I have stolen I think twice in two
different novels because I liked it so
much so shout out to Fran who these days
is doing amazing work on behalf of LGBTQ
youth all over the country and had a
huge huge role in getting marriage
equality the law of the land here in the
United States she's an amazing amazing
person but the point is that you taught
me how to shave and I would say that
that maybe is not like not her number
one area of expertise but I have stuck
with the Fran method for shaving ever
since I have I know of no other method I
mean how is this helpful it's the second
time I shave Hank
every single time I shave even now as a
39 year old person
I hear Fran's voice explaining to me how
to do it and I'll tell you the Fran way
of shaving which is to always shave with
the grain even though it leads to a less
close shave does result in significantly
fewer cuts on on pimples so that is my
advice is the Fran way of Shaving just
don't go against the grain let yourself
not have the cleanest possible shave and
and then you're less likely to burst
those pimples agreed but you will be
even less likely if you get an electric
shaver with a guard and use that which
is basically designed for zero
irritation at all I I mean I've never
even heard of an electric shaver so this
is complete news to me also I will
suggest Google how to safely shave with
acne and I watched a little bit of this
video that this guy made his name's
Brian and it seemed like good advice and
I wished that I had had YouTube videos
to Google and podcasts as
question two when I was shaving around
my terrible spots okay I would I just
want to say one thing here Hank
which is that anybody who ever asks us
any question should just go to Google
dear Google I have the same name as
trumps do FBI director yeah it's gonna
get a way better answer okay let's move
on to a question from Marie who writes
dear Hank and last but not least John
that's honestly that's worse I just I
know that that means but actually least
it always does it oh and the only time
it doesn't mean last but not least is
when it's like a a bunch of people are
being introduced like one time I
remember I was at a movie screening and
they introduced everybody and then they
were like you know and last but not
least shailene woodley and we're all
like oh yeah no you get it Shailene is
the most important person here but
anyway dear Hank and last but not least
John it seems that all mammals except
for orangutangs
chimpanzees gorillas and bonobos can
swim humans can swim too but they have
to actually acquire this skill while all
the other animals capable of swimming
don't my main question is how did humans
start swimming why must this end what
must this individual have been thinking
to come up with this idea I suspect I
suspect that individual was thinking I
want food and there's food in that water
but any additional super extra bonus
question do you think there is a way to
teach one of the apes mentioned above to
swim chutes and ladders murray chutes
and ladders is a great sign off because
just like life that game is completely
arbitrary and right when you think
you're winning it turns out that you are
at your most vulnerable I did a little
bit of research on this and okay
unsurprisingly we aren't sure how many
mammals can swim because we don't make a
habit of just like throwing like the
hundreds of different species of bats
into a lake and seeing what happens hmm
our bats mammals sure they are John
we're pretty I'm pretty sure that there
are a number
mammals that cannot swim armadillos for
example don't to wetland water as you
might expect they're covered in heavy
boney they're not bony plates but heavy
keratinous plates and they don't have
much ability to move their arms so they
just sink
they don't water good just just quick
quick heads up armadillos can swim in
fact they like to swim wait a second not
all the feces I'm just telling you that
I am looking right now at an armadillo
swimming it's sort of a dog paddle thing
I mean I wouldn't say that this
armadillo is an amazing swimmer
I mean it's swimmin I almost want to cut
this out of the podcast because I said
that so confidently and I'm so wrong I
know well it's just it's pretty
difficult actually of the things you say
very confidently I mean this armadillo
isn't only swimming it's diving beneath
the water and like I would argue this
armadillo is actually better a better
swimmer than I am it's amazing
I can you think of another mammal that
might not like to swim that I can
provide a YouTube video providing
evidence so there was I mean there's a
picture here of an armadillo competing
against human swimmers I believe
probably photoshopped but but if I say
it confidently now we've got it
III I'd have to come in and correct you
and be like actually Hank an armadillo
once won a silver medal at the Olympics
in the 200 meter fly his name was Dan I
read an article that was like armadillos
can't swim and I was lied to what other
what hey hank quick question what other
mammals do you think can't swim yeah I
don't I don't know but like I know that
we don't just go around throwing
throwing animals into lakes but okay
well we know so I will also tell you
that like chimpanzees and orangutans
zs-- can swim I don't know about other
these other other primates listed but
but they can it turns out swimming is a
thing but like it is interesting that
humans do have to learn to swim and I'm
curious whether that is the case for
these primates as well like maybe not
all chimpanzees can swim but I don't
know my god I'm watching a video of a
chimpanzee swimming and it is the cutest
thing I have ever seen in my entire life
but oh my god
there are a widespread myth that
chimpanzees can't swim there's a
widespread myth also that camels can't
swim which would make sense because
they're being giant things that live in
the desert and they like have these long
legs that you would imagine don't catch
a lot of water but camels can also swim
this chimpanzee it doesn't just know how
to swim it knows how to tread water so
that it can just stand upright and be
comfortable it this is an amazing pansy
I I don't know if chimpanzees are
eligible for the Olympics but if they
are I think that we've got a serious
issue on our hands we might have seen
the last human swim swimming Olympian
this is amazing oh how many countries
happy about Cooper and he even breathes
underwater he'd be blows bubbles
underwater thank you so much she's like
I been to pool I could take out at the
pool yeah no okay so the answer is I'd
get the answer is that all mammals can
swim period except for humans except for
humans but we can learn how to swim and
I think the reason we struggle with
swimming naturally is I I mean I'm sure
you have to teach chimpanzees a little
bit but I also suspect you have to like
armadillos have to teach other
armadillos probably somehow maybe not I
don't know what do I know I'm so far
outside my area of expertise right now
can the only thing I know for sure is
that I know squirrels can swim because
they can surf yep I haven't found I
haven't found a video of a gorilla
swimming the one that I found clearly is
fake but everybody thinks it's real in
the comments and Wow but apparently
humans are just real bad at stuff that
we have to we have to learn this
seemingly innate skill that all other
mammals have but I think to get to the
point of how did we learn it I mean
there's so much food in the ocean and a
lot of the earliest human well a lot of
successful early human communities lived
near the water yeah yeah either near a
river or near an ocean and at some point
like waiting just becomes not that great
I would also argue though that like
based on watching my kids like you do so
you sort of learn to swim from learning
but you mostly learn to swim from being
in the water you just er do it and
you're like I can catch it I'm catching
on here yeah yeah you start out with the
doggy paddling and then you just kind of
go from there
this question comes from Helen who asks
dear Hank and John I just got a
voicemail on my phone that was not
addressed to me the message seemed
important and urgent even my question to
you is whether I should call back and
tell them that I'm not the person they
intended to call Helen of course you
should Helen it's if it's urgent at
least in the past two notes one how
could you send us this email and not
tell us what the frickin urgent yeah
well I'm stressed out yeah well yeah how
are you
Howard was it was it like was it like
I'm at the hospital my baby did Helen
leave her phone no Helen Helen did not
did not leave her phone number for us
should not leave her phone number
oh my god you got a I got a call you got
a cut you got you got at least he'll
obviously you have to call but we have a
problem now Hank Helen had a problem
which is that she didn't know that she
had to call to let the person know that
they were leaving the voicemail on the
wrong phone but now you and I have a
problem which is that I don't know what
the content of that urgent news was and
until I do I am going to worry that it
was something horrible well you know I
mean it's almost certainly something
like some business thing or like taxes
or something I'd like which is to be
clear horrible and if you know you're
doing something much more it could be
much worse than that it could it could
be I mean it's almost as if one of us
professionally thinks of circumstances
for a living dramatic so I mean and uh
it could Helen I'm gonna need a
follow-up just I need to know that
everything turned out all right or I am
NOT just I'm not gonna be able to close
the loop on that one and it's just gonna
make me miserable so Helen please please
reach back out to us tell me that you're
a regular listener to the pod not
somebody who just dipped in because you
needed advice I can't imagine anybody
comes here for actual advice though
tell me it all worked out okay but yes
if somebody leaves I guess maybe you can
text them III can see how somebody might
do that as a way of trying to like get
you to call back and then maybe it's a
phishing thing you got to be careful
about phishing obviously in every
situation these days but I yeah if it
seemed honest I would worry about it
yeah well I mean in this probably you
can text it right back if it bounces
back and it says it's a landline just
call and be like hey just so you know
yeah it's it's all part of it it's all
part of how the world works we have to
we have to fix it when little things
like that go wrong okay we got a
question for Maddie who writes dear
green brothers I'm 19 years old and I'm
working at my first full-time job the
job is pretty boring in some days it
feels like I don't actually do anything
and I might be working for a fake
company that is a concern if that's a
question I mean I wouldn't say that's a
concern I would say that it's a point of
interest though however this
quote-unquote company gives me an hour
for lunch and I have no idea what to do
with it
some days I have a car so I'll Drive
around a bit but that waste gas and
kills future children what could I do
for an extra hour touch touch touch not
the cat without a glove
Maddie which is good life advice I don't
know if there's anything else to that
quote like I don't know if it's from
Shakespeare so it's it's from from her
clan from clam chattin which is the clan
of the cats it's the Scottish clan motto
which means don't meddle with us or
we'll get you back harder basically it
says in the PS here
sweet sweet yeah I want to have a clan
motto hey why don't we have a clan ball
because we're Irish John oh yeah I
forgot about that yeah you know some
somewhere our great-grandfather's are
like standing up out of the grave
screaming at us for saying that we
wanted to be Scottish there was not a
lot that our grandfather green cared
about more than that we understood that
we were Irish and not only Irish but
that we were a particular political
persuasion of Irish but we don't need to
get into at the moment
Hank yeah Mady is working for a fake
company that gives her an hour for lunch
isn't it possible Mady that you're just
working for a company that doesn't isn't
just isn't doing a lot of business at
the moment and that they're giving you
an hour for lunch because that's what
any normal employer would do yeah an
hour for lunch isn't isn't super
uncommon and it shouldn't be geez I mean
I yeah I've definitely not gotten an
hour for lunch some but but I mean like
I can't I got like what do you do for a
normal hour you have a phone right like
E is there Wi-Fi cuz I think bring a
book or bring the blanket you know John
when I worked at Walmart I would like
take books from Walmart and read them
and then return them to the shelves ya
know that works I mean there's no reason
you can't do that so if you're in in a
place where there are books just take
existing books read them and return them
to the shelves otherwise go to your
local public library get a book and
enjoy that hour of reading per day as
kind of a relaxation although it sounds
like potentially your job itself is
pretty relaxing since there don't seem
to be any customers well yeah I mean I
think you should definitely listen to
podcasts but yeah you don't have to like
you don't usually have to leave during
your lunch break do they hat like there
should be a place where you can go
during that time and sit around lists
maybe they're like Maddie we're gonna
need you to leave for an hour for your
lunch break right cuz we're then Maddie
has to be like okay I'll see and then
she has to leave and that's when I
launder the money the drugs know they're
laundering the money right there it was
there was a store in Lincoln Square in
Chicago where I lived for many years and
we were all pretty sure that it was a
front for something and we would always
make a joke about it we'd always be like
there's nobody ever in that place it
must be a front for something and then
one day the FBI came and it was a front
for something in mom and dad's town - it
was like this like hotdog place and it
turned out that they weren't having like
high-stakes gambling in the back oh yeah
I remember that no this was a this was a
straight money laundering operation it
was straight laundering of drug money
and they they were they were saying that
they you know were a wildly popular
business and there was literally never
anyone in there
and when you would go in there the
service you got was exceptionally weird
and poor so I don't know Maddie if
you've been told to be super rude to
customers to try to keep them out but if
you have that might be another red flag
that you might be working for a front
business yeah but well I mean you'll
guess what's what's the thing to do if
you are actually working for a front
business are you just like well I'm not
gonna rattle the cage here cuz I don't
want to get in trouble with the law or
also the potential mafia that I'm
working for I think if you're working
for a front business and you know you're
working for a front business you
probably have a legal and ethical
obligation not to turn them in
necessarily but to maybe submit your
notice yeah bill I have all I got it's
great opportunity working yeah I just
got this I just yeah by the way if you
need an excuse just tell them that
you're coming to work for us hey mafia
boss my podcast got really big so I'm
doing that full-time now and they'll be
like what is that and they're like it's
an internet thing don't worry about it
yeah and then they'll be like you need
some protection for that podcast and
you'll be like no I don't think so and
then the next week sure that that's how
are your podcast is gonna be destroyed
and you'll be like oh yeah I've got a
protection money for my podcast wow I
just said throw a window through your
podcast which is not really what I meant
but also also bad like you don't want
someone to throw a window through your
window yeah that's worse than a brick
very bad much worse the glass yeah so
much broken glass of cleanup if nothing
else maybe it was a double paned window
that they threw through your wind we
need a podcast mafia it's a great
business idea Hank like the number one
thing that podcasts are missing right
now is an organized crime syndicate that
extracts value out of podcasts it's good
we I mean if anybody can do don't you
don't you think that it would be us I
mean we don't have a strong criminal
past but we do have a strong past of
organizing creators around certain goals
and this would just be organizing
creators around the goals of not getting
your podcast destroyed by Hank and John
Green well John this this podcast of
course is in fact brought to you by the
podcast mafia the podcast mafia already
exists were just very secret about it
because we don't want anyone to know
that that's how we make the majority of
our ma I mean if you're in the Mafia
Hank you don't brag about being in the
Mafia all the time you just make jokes
like hah hah hah hah hah hah hah brought
to you by our Irish grandfather our
Irish grandfather definitely in favor of
the unification of Ireland this podcast
is also brought to you by the word y'all
the word y'all it's the best plural you
and lastly this podcast is brought to
you by that big oh my gosh moment in the
second Star Wars movie that big oh my
gosh moment I'm sorry you're my what now
alright John do you want to do one more
question before we move on to the news
from Mars and AFC Wimbledon ha
we got long enough cuz we seem to have
gone oh yeah we went way too long Hank
we gotta move out of the newsroom Mars
and AFC Wimbledon especially guys it's
the offseason so there's so much news
mmm I feel yeah it's always the
offseason for Mars there are seasons on
Mars and they're all odd alright alright
what is it in a new paper SpaceX founder
and do you know it basically inventor of
everything Elon Musk has made his
argument for a self-sustaining city on
Mars so not just going to Mars he wants
to build a place that can make us a
multiplanetary species because he's not
busy enough trying to make every tesla
supercharged station solar-powered and
also create a Hyperloop system so that
we can have pneumatic tubes that connect
our cities together but also be be a
species that has a back-up plan
not that I think it's a good backup plan
as I have said before reiterate bad
if earth goes kaput Mars will be a
couple years behind I don't and unless
we're talking about like a ten thousand
year backup plan
so an even as a as a ten thousand year
backup plan we need a much more
earth-like planet I would argue well we
in ten thousand years we could make Mars
amore earth-like planet John maybe may I
mean I don't know I haven't seen a lot
of evidence for that but then again to
be fair ten thousand years ago we were
just starting to think about agriculture
so maybe I'm not being fair so that's
very true so in his in his little paper
here Elon Musk he says that he's looking
for a 10-year time frame for sending the
first colonists he says that is feasible
John what year is it right now 2017 and
how when is ten years from now
it's 2027 hmm
oh I would be shaking in my boots if you
on musk had ever made a deadline ever
anyway you know what Hank I believe I'll
believe that humans will be on Mars in
2027 when my Tesla Model 3 costing
$42,000 arrives at my house in 2013
[Laughter]
there's a huge amount of risk it's going
to cost a lot there's a good chance we
will not succeed but we're going to do
our best to try and make as much
progress as possible so he also doesn't
think he's gonna do it yeah I mean I I
appreciate his honesty the news from AFC
Wimbledon is as always it's complex Hank
you know the biggest dream for most AFC
Wimbledon supporters aside from getting
back into the Football League is to be
back in Wimbledon right now they play in
Kingston at Kings meadow they want to
build their own Stadium they want to be
back in Wimbledon at plough lane or
across the street from the historic
plough
and there is a plan to do that and
everything is lined up there the
financing is lined up everything has
been agreed to the plans have been
agreed to
it's just now there is one more hurdle
to jump over which is that some people
are saying that the greyhound stadium
that will be demolished to make room for
plow Lane which is a greyhound racing
station a stadium and not I have to say
just being perfectly honest a
particularly beautiful one should be
listed as a historic place in England
which would make it impossible to ever
do anything to it you know like how
Westminster Abbey is a historic place so
you can't tear down Westminster Abbey
and build something else on its on its
place which is a lovely idea I don't
feel the same way about greyhound
stadiums myself but that decision was
delayed by the election before snap
elections no decisions can be made
before within six weeks before an
election so as not to use the political
process to affect outcomes which is a
good rule I think but an annoying one in
this case and the instability that
resulted from the strangeness of the
vote has left the whole affair a little
bit up in the air so we don't know quite
where it stands and we don't know quite
when it will be decided and we don't
know quite what will be decided that
appears to be the last actually last
hurdle to Wimbledon's plough Lane dream
to being a team with a stadium in
Wimbledon again and closing the loop on
this very difficult chapter this now 25
year long chapter in their history so
I'll keep you updated on that but that's
the current situation thank you for
keeping us updated I'm sorry
apparent that you apparently did not get
any new players in the last week oh yes
we did not we did lose a couple new
players though we lost uh yeah it's not
great well I mean this is the nature of
ball in the third tier like Tom Eliot
got a job playing in the second tier
which is incredible for him and who
would blame him for taking it and then a
another player who's been really really
good for us left for the Scottish League
where he'll be in the top league in
Scotland and get to play Celtic and
Rangers and that's a cool I mean that's
an amazing opportunity so you can't you
can't tell players like Tom Eliot or
Sean Kelly not to move on when they have
those opportunities all you can hope is
that if AFC Wimbledon is the kind of
club that builds and nurtures players to
make them good enough to make those
jumps that more players will want to
come and play at Wimbledon because
they'll recognize that it's the kind of
club where you become a stronger player
and can move up the leaks well John what
did we learn today well we learned that
Hank and I are running a protection
racket in the podcast game
we learned that armadillos can swim and
so can everything apparently everything
cans when everything swims we learned
that bugs poop they do John they're
they're just a tube stuff goes in one
side and out the other and of course we
learned that the Russians are coming for
us and we welcome them we welcome them
with open arms you seem great great no
issues there at all and again we want to
say for the record because we do have a
lot of Russian listeners who sometimes
take offense and with good reason to the
idea of the Russians as a mono yeah
which of course they are not so let's
just be specific we learned that Putin
is coming and we think we think that
that we are in great hands
sure yeah don't leave our emails alone
thanks strong capable very strong hands
so so strong so strong they're going to
hold us so tight so tight we're going to
be like it's a little too tight
a little bit white-knuckle grip on the
reins of your of your horse
of control and on that note thanks for
listening to dear Hank and John a comedy
podcast about mostly these days Suton
this podcast is edited by Nicholas
Jenkins it's produced by rosianna halse
rojas and sheridan Gibson our social
media manager is Victoria Bongiorno our
music is by the great gunnarolla if you
want to email us your questions you can
do that in Hank and John at gmail.com
we're also on Twitter Hank green and
John Green that's us
work that's we got we got our own names
on Twitter because we're great
we're early now you'd be word early you
did something to do that didn't you John
the important thing actually is that I'm
not on Twitter I haven't written one of
my own tweets in almost six months well
you can send us your Hank echad
questions there though and we'll find
them and I think all I have to say now
is as they say in our hometown don't
forget
[Music]